[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
voilà savoir faire avec les différences
je pense que c'est ce dont on a besoin
aujourd'hui et c'est ça que j'essaye
d'explorer avec vous mais avec mes
moyens les moyens à moi c'est les mots
si je suis une exploratrice de quelque
chose c'est une exploratrice de ce que
peuvent les mots et plus exactement
encore pour moi la difference savoir
faire avec les différences
ça peut se construire autour d'une
pratique et d'une idée qui est celle de
la traduction entre deux cultures entre
deux langues est la traduction
ce savoir faire avec les différences
c'est comme ça que je définis m'a donné
envie et m'a donné besoin de fabriquer
un projet à peu un peu fou je le
reconnais dans lequel je voudrais vous
entraîner ce projet c'est un projet que
j'ai appelée maison de la sagesse bayt
al hikma c'est un vieux truc de bagdad
au xvième siècle mais c'étaient des
maisons qui étaient construites autour
de la traduction ou tout le monde venait
tous les savants tous les pays toutes
les générations et il traduisait
simplement qu'est ce que ça serait une
maison de sagesse aujourd'hui au 21ème
siècle
à marseille par exemple ou à
aubervilliers qui sont mes deux terrains
de travail
ils ont la sagesse vous voyez c'est ça
hein
les la manière dont s'était représenté
en perse
à bagdad des livres beaucoup de livres
mais des gens beaucoup de gens alors
qu'est ce que ça serait une maison de la
sagesse aujourd'hui bien moi ce le
déclic pour vouloir faire cela c'est une
phrase est un chiffre la phrase c'est
celle ci une phrase d'hannah arendt qui
a écrit
en exil et elle écrit manifestement
personne ne veut savoir que l'histoire
contemporaine a engendré un nouveau type
d'êtres humains ceux qui ont été envoyés
dans les camps de concentration par
leurs ennemis et dans les camps
d'internement par leurs amis phrase pas
n'importe quoi et le chiffre c'est par
exemple celui du nombre de noyés en 2016
le nombre de noyés en méditerranée ce
qu'on a pu comptabiliser 5000 mais c'est
ce qu'on a pu comptabiliser et voilà je
me suis dit que il fallait arrêter
d'avoir la flemme qu'il fallait arrêter
d'avoir peur qu'il fallait sortir de cet
imaginaire dément d'une société sans
étrangers et tenter avec chacun ses
moyens de fabriquer quelque chose comme
dix ont une société d'hospitalité avec
ce magnifique mots en français oat qui
veut dire celui qui accueille et celui
qui est accueilli les deux dents dans
une réciprocité parfaite donc une
société disons d'hospitalité réciproque
et pourquoi la traduction me paraît le
bon moyen de faire ça et bien parce que
c'est une hospitalité de langue à langue
il y avait un troubadour dans le
languedoc qui disait voilà traduire
c'est l'auberge du lointain
voilà soyons un peu l'auberge du
lointain et voilà pourquoi je vais vous
proposer de réfléchir avec moi ces
maisons la sagesse j'étais à calais par
exemple et voilà la photo que j'ai prise
à calais démantèlement de la zone sud
plus rien cette pancarte ouvrant sur du
vide sur des bouts de de jouets qui
traînait cette pancarte qui a dit qu'à
une école qui avaient été fabriqués
construite par les gens eux-mêmes
l'école des dunes
mais il y avait plus que cette pancarte
dans toutes les langues et pour vous
dire comment j'en suis arrivée là je
vais faire un tout petit bout de
parcours vous ai dit que j'étais
spécialiste de philosophie grecque
oui c'est vrai que mes premières
traductions ma première étonnement mon
premier étonnement de langue c'est entre
le grec ancien et le français il ya un
mot grec qui est véritablement
intraduisible qui arrête c'est le mot
logos logos ça veut dire à la fois
discours parole moreau tout ce que vous
voudrez comme sa démonstration de sape
et raison discours et raison d'ailleurs
les latins traduit par ratio est au
ratio un jeu de mots discours raison et
élan grecque
autrement dit les grecs ont le logos ils
ont le discours et la raison c'est comme
ça qu'ils se voient ils se voient
propriétaire de l'universel et c'est ce
dont nous héritons et nous héritons de
cela à savoir que les autres sont des
barbares
j'ai fait une exposition au mucem que
peut-être certains d'entre vous ont vu
je crois qu'il y avait je me trompe pas
60000 personnes qui nous donc j'étais
peut-être dedans dans cette exposition
mucem sap qui s'appelait après babel
traduire vous voyez babel babel babil
bla bla bla barbares barbara moi tout ça
c'est la même chose 1
c'est ce qu'on ne comprend pas c'est une
onomatopée pour dire ce qu'on ne
comprend pas et du coup quand les grecs
définissent l'homme comme un animal doué
de logos à celui qui ne comprennent pas
celui qui n'a pas le logos pas tout à
fait sûr ça soit un homme un un barbare
n'est pas vraiment un homme est dans ce
mur des barbares vous voyez ce
magnifique bla bla bla qui est une
tableau contemporain de mel bochner et
puis à côté vous voyez des vases qui a
dicté des barbares grecque figurent des
barbares grecque
et puis nous parce qu'on est toujours le
barbare de quelqu'un nous alors je sais
pas si c'est à droite ou à gauche parce
que
bon c'est là nous caravaniers au long
nez nous le barbare des chinois voilà et
puis un bien une poupée berbère de
l'autre côté ce que tout ça c'est la
même chose c'est de l'autre c'est de
l'autre qu'on ne comprend pas c'est à
dire aussi c'est de l'autre qu'on ne
traduit pas et vous voyez pourquoi je
m'intéresse à ce point là à quelque
chose comme une maison de la sagesse
je la remets qui soit un lieu de
traduction pas forcément une maison qui
a des portes et des fenêtres ni des
livres bien que ça puisse aider mais
disons un réseau un dispositif de lieu
et d'action
et ce sont de ces lieux et de ses
actions dont je veux vous parler
maintenant
alors le premier la première action
c'est l'action de l'accueil on accueille
comment est-ce qu'on accueille bas on
accueille en ne se prenant pas soi-même
pour l'universel en se prenant pas soi
même pour le tour du monde
on accueille en faisant attention aux
différences et l'une des choses que
j'avais fait dans cette exposition au
mucem qui m'a beaucoup apporté
avec toutes les associations avec des
associations qui allait aussi dans les
baumettes etc
c'était de poser la question quel est le
mot de votre langue maternelle qui vous
manque le plus quand vous êtes en
français quel est le mot qui vous manque
le plus et on a obtenu 7 6 mais ce qui
était magnifique du mot qui vous manque
et par exemple il y avait une femme ça
m'a beaucoup marqué parce qu'on
demandait aux gens mais pourquoi ça vous
manque
donc il y avait une femme qui disait ben
voila moi en arabe je sais dire comment
je laime je laime à vouloir mourir avant
lui si je dis ça en français c'est
ridicule
il ya un mot en arabe pour le dire donc
voilà alors la cimaise du mot qui vous
manque j'ai retravaillé ça avec un des
lieux qui pourrait être une maison de la
sagesse
un des collèges un collège à la belle de
mai à la friche belle de mai un collège
et voilà ce que ces classes de
collégiens primo-arrivants où l'on parle
20 langues
voilà par exemple la démo qu'ils m'ont
donnée merci merci et yaou un mot
arménien qui veut dire ça manque est
encore plus que ça donc l'accueil
glossaire de la bureaucratie française
je vous propose ça c'est à dire que
quand les gens arrivent
non seulement il ya des mots qui
manquent mais on fait comme si ils
étaient comme nous comme s'il y avait
aucune différence c'est à dire comme si
par exemple aux tamouls qui arrivent
comme s'il pouvait répondre à la
question est ce que vous êtes mariés
divorcés pacsés on demande quel est
votre ni quel âge avez vous c'est pas du
tout si simple votre nom et votre prénom
mais c'est pas du tout si simple ça ne
va pas de soi d'avoir un nom et un
prénom ça ne va pas de soi d'avoir une
date de naissance stabiliser ça ne va
pas de soi de savoir si on est réfugié
expatriés c'est à toutes ces catégories
sont des catégories qui nous renvoie à
nos schémas et ce glossaire de la
bureaucratie française qu'on est en
train de faire avec les primo arrivants
avec leurs enfants et les parents
et bien c'est quelque chose qui doit
faire réfléchir l'administration en
retour ne pas croire que c'est si simple
les valeurs de la république ne pas
croire que un questionnaire
administratif ça ne contient pas déjà
plein de jugement plein de préjugés
plein de culture pour le meilleur et
pour le pire
donc vous voyez premières actions de ces
maisons de la sagesse l'accueil
deuxième action que j'appellerais d'un
mot que j'adore pas l'insertion
il se trouve que on a beaucoup travaillé
à marseille justement à la suite de
cette exposition et en particulier avec
un organisme que je trouve magique qui
est là dit c'est à dire les led micro au
micro au microcrédit par le micro crédit
aux entreprises et aux entrepreneurs qui
veulent faire quelque chose et là
ce que nous nous proposons c'est de
valoriser le parcours de vie des gens
qui comme ça arrivent à bénéficier d'un
microcrédit
alors on a travaillé avec les arts de la
rue par exemple avec générik vapeur et
on a vu
on a choisi des parcours qui nous
paraissaient très important qui nous
paraissaient montrer ce qu'est un
patrimoine migrateurs vous voyez ça
c'est une main de fatma qui figure qui
est posée aux murs d'un restaurant
mexicain ouvert par un berbère bon alors
un restaurant mexicain ouvert par un
berbère qui fait dessiner par une de ses
amies à aix une main de fatma mais comme
si c'était frida kahlo qu'il avait
peinte et ben ils l'expliquent et ça si
vous voulez c'est une
c'est une extraordinaire appréhension de
son patrimoine migrateurs alors je vous
en montre d'autre voilà c'est un
restaurant aussi haïtien et vous voyez
vous avez un planteur et devant le pont
de brooklyn
eh ben c'est comme ça chez eugénie c'est
comme ça c'est entre le pont de brooklyn
et un planteur haïtien et là vous avez
là relents la relance et ce comme ça
qu'on appelait cette bagnole
complètement folle à l'intérieur qu'on a
complètement désossé qu'on a refaite en
hommage et avec un garagiste dont qui
avait bénéficié d'un microcrédit pour
créer son garage un garagiste russe et à
l'intérieur quand on est d'ambon les
sièges sont bouleversés on entend son
histoire de vie on entend ce qu'ils
racontent de son garage
donc vous voyez le deuxième temps c'est
cette espèce de deux rapports à l'autre
avec des objets et leur histoire
quelque chose comme une banque musée et
nous avons déjà fait ça par exemple
en afrique des banques musée comme ça
c'est à dire des objets leur histoire et
un microcrédit et le troisième c'est
encore plus compliqué la troisième chose
dont je voudrais vous parler
la troisième action que je mène dans ces
maisons de la sagesse et que je voudrais
que nous menions
c'est une action de réflexion un pas en
arrière sur ce qui bloque et ce qui
bloque aujourd'hui peut-être plus que
tout c'est les fondamentalismes c'est à
dire les les religions exacerbée et pour
essayer alors en méditerranée c'est les
trois monothéismes la torah la bible le
coran pour essayer que ça se débloque un
peu qu'on puisse parler et bien nous
faisons un travail sur ce que j'appelle
les intraduisible des trois monothéismes
ça veut pas du tout dire que ça se
traduit pas ça veut dire qu'on
réfléchisse ensemble à comment est ce
qu'on dit dieu dans ses livres dits
sacrés dans ces langues
comment est ce qu'on dit dieu comment
est ce qu'on dit le livre comment est ce
qu'on dit de l'autre comme on dit la
communauté comme on dit la femme
et là je vous montre la violence des
traductions
ici vous avez d'une part une bible et
qui est reprise éternellement par les
images de catéchisme vous avez eve qui
est sorti de la côte d'adam
c'est l'homme seul m le mot pour dire qu
autre d'habitude dans toute la torah
ça se traduit par à côté d'eux alors
rêve elle est sortie de la côte d'adam
c'est un petit bout de mecs c'est la
femme c'est un sous-homme un petite
portion comme ça ou bien ou bien elle
est née à côté de lui et c'est rodin la
main de la main de dieu qui représente
l'homme et la femme en train de
s'éveiller ensemble et ça c'est un effet
de traduction est-ce que vous choisissez
que sève pour autant que healy et eve
est ce que vous choisissez qu'elle est
qu'elle soit née de la côte d'adam ou
est-ce que vous choisissez qu'elle se
soit éveillée à côté d'adam mais voilà
le genre de choses que nous avons
à travailler donc vous voyez maison de
la sagesse un réseau de lieu et d'action
ces actions pour l'instant elles ont été
faites avec beaucoup d'acteurs
marseillais beaucoup d'acteurs à
aubervilliers et elles sont centrées sur
trois temps trois temporalités l'accueil
l'insertion et le pas en arrière la
réflexion voilà c'est maison de la
sagesse dans lesquels je voudrais vous
entraînez parce que chacun ait pu y
aller avec ses moyens
chacun doit y faire quelque chose qu'il
sait faire qu'il peut faire et voilà
aristote disait la démocratie c'est le
moins mauvais des régimes dits l'époque
c'était bien c'est le moins mauvais des
régimes et puis il ajoutait et si je
cherche un bon modèle de démocratie
peut-être que le meilleur modèle c'est
le pique nique
c'est à dire chacun apporte ce qu'il a
si tout le monde à porter tomates c'est
la catastrophe
mais si chacun apporte ce qu'il a alors
on peut peut-être faire quelque chose
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]